on me parle pas ça casse mon rythme on a
un souci
il ya du mouvement
on a quinze minutes c'est le moment
envoyez salut les gars
et si je te disais
que je sais ce qui se passe après la
mort
on devient un fantôme
plus de casier judiciaire les fêtes de
bureau plus de mariages à l'est est ce
qu'il ya de mieux quand tu es mort c'est
que tu es libre
plus de politiques plus de diplomatie
personne n'y touche notamment
[Musique]
plus de comptes à rendre à qui que ce
soit
on peut éliminer quelques beau [ __ ]
on est piégé dans l'escalier j'ai une
super mauvaise idée gâtés mauvaise idée
trouvant une panne
c'était bien la mission
[Musique]
ils sont tous officiellement mort les
gens se souviendront pas de nous mais
ils se souviendront de cette journée
bonne action peuvent effacer les mauvais
jours vous êtes qui vous autres
plus personne ils sont peut-être pas
vraiment mort
mais ça peut s'arranger ils ont des
avions de chasse tu vois ce que joie
ouais tu vois que tu joues à luz
non
désolé d'avoir crié et avenue à bord du
plus gros aimant du monde tu es un grand
malade
grenade
[Musique]
oh
je n'étais pas sûr que ça marche
enfin pas sûr à 100% je m'en doutais
seulement mais on est en séries beaucoup
trop dangereux
il ne s'agira pas d'une guerre de héros
ce qui veut dire que ça va être amusant
le monde brûle
vous n'avez pas idée de ce dont les
hommes sont capables
nous devons intervenir
je comprends que vous ayez envie de vous
battre
les idées à d'autres façons d'accomplir
votre devoir il va vous falloir un
costume suivez moi nous sommes la
première agence de renseignement
indépendante maintenir la paix et
protéger la vie et avenue clap l'ampleur
de sa puissance
[Musique]
chez aux ennemis
pense que nous sommes des gentlemen
mais la réputation c'est ce que les gens
pensent de vous
le caractère c'est ce que vous êtes
armés et prêts
ar mais oui
m haies on va voir ça
bon
ceux ci
s'appelle un parachute ça permet de
sauter d'un aéroplane sans se blesser
[Musique]
je m'appelle et j'habite près d'ici je
m'appelle elie ils disent que vous êtes
allergique au monde si ça continue je
crois qu'on peut dire soir il a cherché
partout un spécialiste qui pourrait
aider
tu vas aller mieux promis
promis
bonjour il y je soumets docteur horn
bonjour j'espère que tu ne vois pas ça
comme une clinique pour moi c'est un
foyer et pour l'instant c'est envoyé ça
fait si longtemps
toutes les choses pour lesquelles j'ai
prié sont ici on commence tôt ma vie
qu'est ce qui te rend malade
beaucoup de choses l'air l'eau la
poussière l'état délit va s'aggraver
avant de s'améliorer
il y avait quelque chose dans ma chambre
les cauchemars font partie des effets
secondaires c'est parfaitement normal je
vais pas te faire peur mais cet endroit
ça me fait flipper je crois qu'elles
meurent encore plus malade c'est le
traitement qui fait c'est pas le
traitement qui fait ça et si ça marche
alors pourquoi je me sens encore plus
mal parce que ça marche
il s'est passé un truc grave ici
[Musique]
absolument pas tout de suite ce que sa
vie est en danger
pourquoi tu fais ça tu es plus malade
que tu ne le croirait chez l'homme
approché je suis pas malade
mais sûrement sortir mais
tu vas aller mieux promis
[Musique]
ce gamin ne se croyait pas à la hauteur
j'ai cru que c'était seulement la peur
alors gelé pris sous mon aile
il avait raison d'avoir peur
il arbore l échec le plus important des
services secrets
de notre histoire ça ne peut plus se
reproduire
rectifier ça
[Musique]
on a au moins certains qui veulent se
battre
les japonais prépare quelque chose de
plus gros et quelle est la cible on
pense que ce bédouin washington n'est
pas d'accord
washington se trompent
si on perd
les japonais envahiront la côte ouest
seattle san francisco à los angeles
[Musique]
seront réduits en cendres
nous avons l'ordre d'attaquer il faut
frapper un grand coup qui se rendent
bien compte de ce que ça fait
[Musique]
de douzaine d'avions
contre toute la flotte japonaise
[Musique]
ça n'est pas un combat équitable
je ne sais pas comment guider cesarani
qui te suivront jusqu'au bout
tu sais que tu as fait ce qu'il fallait
quand les autres compter sur toi
tu pourras tout affronter
frank sheeran
ça oui c'est bien ça selon votre contrat
le management de police ancien chauffeur
qu'en cas de faute lourde
alors vous êtes parfois en retard les
infractions au code de la route non ou
buvez au travail non vous n'avez frappé
personne au travail oui j'ai pas
l'impression
et bien parce que nous n'avons pas à
nous en faire vous présente mon cousin
russell de falgos à saly enchanté
c'était comme à l'armée sur sub et les
hommes surgissent tiflet
ont été récompensés
nos amis a désormais en ce moment un ami
qui est au sommet à l'époque il n'y
avait pas une seule personne dans tout
le pays qui ne savait pas qui était
jimmy hoffa toujours attaqué l'équipe
quand un pistolet mais les couteaux il
faut [ __ ] le camp armes à feu on
attaque et poignard on se bat à l'écran
qui te contribué à écrire cette page
d'histoire oui les grandes entreprises
du gouvernement se sont associés pour
essayer de nous détruire ouverte le jour
qu'est-ce qu'il a encore dit c'est pas
bon d'avoir des secrets entrer en guerre
avec ses fils ok les choses ont encore
dégénéré avec vraiment j'aime et
asseyons nous tous les quatre photos
discipline je refuse de m'asseoir c'est
au-dessus de départ
les jeux sont faits et le jean que je
sais des choses est ce que je sais ils
savent patch de seine
et ça se passera comme ça qu'on le
veuille ou pas son compte est bon
peu m'importe que vous l'ayez fait ou
pas en fait ça ne change rien pour moi
et je sais je suis ici pour vous
défendre
ok ok vous vous demandez si je suis
coupable willens aurait bien
[Musique]
mon envie
c'est calme ici ce soir ouais je peux
enfin t'avoir pour moi tout seul
[Musique]
les mecs prunelli santé sont de
bouteilles
c'est sûrement à l'un des petits jeunes
avec qui tu discuté hier soir il y avait
aussi des étudiants à ces jeunes dans le
bar ils ont laissé un portable alors
j'ai fouiné dans pour trouver le
propriétaire tu veux pas voir ça tu veux
pas voir ça c'est affreux là où faire
quelque chose j'ai peur très peur aussi
tu sais que si tu veux parler à
quelqu'un je suis là
tu as l'air super coupable
[Musique]
ils m'ont obligé à le faire
mon paradis c'est ça avoir tous vos yeux
braqués sur moi tous les soirs antennes
dans 5 4 3 2
bonsoir à tous ce soir à tout ce soir à
tous
[Musique]
oui je suis le roi
sarr du paf producteurs
[Musique]
je suis tout simplement indéboulonnable
je vous aime tous
antenne dans huit secondes
nous informer chaque soir et annule en
sonar nom et en plaisir aussi
les audiences de votre jt ne vous
protégeront pas indéfiniment
il m'impressionnait pas ça gueule ça
viendra
[Musique]
hérode % de parts de marché à soir non
danse de joie
trouvez-moi des failles de ce fils de
[ __ ] encore 1 ce matin le coût du
cercueil quand même essayer le monde
dedans vous regardez trop les infos
qu'est ce que vous voulez qui m'arrive
c'est bien kahn a encore qui vont dire
que ça me ressemble mais moi je dirais
plutôt une femme
le nom catalogue qui peut se comporter
comme ça je crois que j'ai ma petite
idée
[Musique]
dino
il maintient
c'est
akio
puis une taille
[Musique]
tant mieux
de nairobi ont marre de tout mais je
craque
[Musique]
ce qui m'a dépassé
cinq ans
[Musique]
en demies
les managers seniors likes famille
[Musique]
aujourd'hui